[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMEER IYENGAR: Beautylish is
a virtual makeup counter.
We have a huge community of
people sharing looks,
tutorials, and reviews to help
each other find products and
brands that would work
really well for them.
Our Sign-In integration helps
personalize the experience for
new users by finding people's
friends from their Circles who
are already on Beautylish and
then using that information to
recommend them content
that they might like.
DAMIEN PATTON: Banjo is
real-time content
discovery by location.
We're using Google+ profile data
to create Banjo profiles
so we don't have to recreate
the wheel.
Google+ Sign-In integration
was really easy.
It just took about a day, and
already we could share amazing
content, connecting with people
in our Google+ Circles.